Luis Pozuelo está trabajando duro el
candidato republicano por El séptimo
distrito de Arizona se enfrenta a una
ardua batalla intentando dejar su huella
en una zona que ha votado azul durante
dos décadas
este empresario llegó de Uruguay hace 20
años con el tiempo se irritó con lo que
denomina como una retórica negativa de
los demócratas a los latinos decirles
que el sueño americano ha muerto
decirles que este es un país
sistemáticamente racista que no pueden
tener éxito en este país porque son
morenos o porque tienen un acento como
el mío o porque no han nacido aquí yo
mismo soy la prueba de que todo eso que
dicen los demócratas No es cierto
antes de estas elecciones María nunca se
había metido en política pero este año
está llamando a las puertas por Luis
Pozuelo y dice que su herencia ha
influido en esa decisión
latinos en spanish los latinos e
hispanos piensan de forma diferente
somos una cultura diferente estamos
consiguiendo candidatos que se dan
cuenta de lo que necesitamos y de cuáles
son nuestras necesidades pueden
relacionarse con nuestras tradiciones
con nuestros valores con nuestra
integridad
y el partido republicano lo ha entendido
ha abierto 38 centros de acercamiento a
las minorías en todo el país para
dirigirse mejor a determinadas
comunidades
y también está presentando un número
récord de candidatos latinos soy Juan y
a prueba este mensaje la razón por la
que el grupo es tan codiciado es que en
las elecciones de medio término los
latinos acuden a las urnas mucho menos
que otros grupos demográficos esta
organización no política Está tratando
de despertar al Gigante Dormido
queremos que la gente de la comunidad
latina hable de política en la mesa
donde no sea una vergüenza decir a quién
te interesa conocer o votar
en 2050 El 29% de los estadounidenses
serán de ascendencia Latina una
comunidad cuya influencia en la política
estadounidense solo está destinada a